oh hi you know Apple's iPhone has
actually been out for over five years
now and it's amazing what it has done
for video games only for the fact that
it has reduced prices down to as low as
99 cents you can buy amazing video games
for under a buck and this of course has
caused me major problems because I
recently passed a milestone I actually
have run out of icons spaces on my
iphones menu for all of the crap that I
have now Apple solution for this is
probably to just make me buy an iphone 5
so I can get that extra row of icons I
think I have a better idea and I think I
it's actually time for me to go in and
delete some of this stuff now I have
blown 99 cents on all kinds of garbage
so it should be pretty easy to get rid
of some stuff off this iphone so let's
do that oh right infinity sword yeah
well not not infinity blade mind you
which is the amazing sword fighting game
from epic but infinity sword a total
knockoff meant to trick people into
buying the wrong game oh man this was
funny at the time it's it's pretty bad
it's not available in the iTunes Store
anymore but look oh man it's hilarious
look at this you did this sword hits the
balls when you tap on them and that's it
ball game though the other half of the
game is this just a bunch of stolen
JPEGs that you can just look at oh man
this thing was evil genius how could i
get rid of this I can't oh the bed
intruder soundboard created so quickly
to capitalize on antoine dodson's 15
minutes of fame let me look you need
this sometimes in the middle of a
conversation you realize that any words
that you could use personally are just
entirely pointless and only antoine
dodson can capture the perfect bond mode
well obviously we have a rapist other
people up tryna hide your kids hide your
wife cause they rapin everybody out here
yeah oh no no I can't get rid of this
either not here we go this is garbage 3d
cartoon land Safari look it's not super
mario 3d land no no
way just look at the turtles are red
wait no no no mario has great turtles I
think anyway the guy's hair is blonde
and he has no mustache that puts them
legally totally in the clear this game
is junk it's completely impossible to
play uh no this is too funny I can't get
rid of this uh okay well we're out of
time and apparently I am no closer to
clearing out my iphone but we have
learned something today I should never
be given money